mcdonald's has opened its first uk net
zero restaurant today but the chain
which relies heavily on meat and dairy
has been accused of green washing it
says the restaurant is just one part of
its net zero plans but whatever the
merits of one company's plans isn't the
very fact that the private sector is
attempting to go carbon neutral helpful
for the planet so chile let's talk very
generally shall we um should we be
encouraged that companies are
increasingly wanting to be part of the
climate change conversation and want to
be seen to be green
thank you very much for that well i
think the fact that so many large
companies are very publicly pivoting
towards net net zero is an indication
that we've won the argument it's an
indication that environmentalists are
being proven to have been right all
along
but
as they join our side of the argument
they need to be exact they need to have
plans that are functionally correct and
it's very very important that their
transition plans are managed by their
operations
not their marketing departments so
mcdonald's can have great adverts with
good-looking artists and beautiful young
children but if they don't take care of
their supply chain
if they don't make sure that they
responsibly source the things that we
eat if they don't make sure that they
don't encourage farmers to destroy the
ecosystems and farm in our system
at the end of the day they still
contribute to the problem and that has
to change
jen would you agree with that i mean is
transparency at the heart of this and
how much do we have at the moment
we don't have much transparency at all
at the moment when it comes to net zero
plans especially by private corporations
they're
it's very rare to see any sort of
published statements about
what they're including in their
accounting how much they're going to
reduce their emissions how much they're
going to offset
and if a whole bunch of companies are
thinking of offsetting
well that means we're going to need
countries the size of brazil to just be
for us only for company maybe like shell
so we need to know in terms of planning
what countries or what companies are
going to do
in order to have any hope of figuring
out if these net zero pledges are
realistic
so the secretary general has an effort
underway he announced at the glasgow
climate cop that he's going to bring
together some experts to start thinking
about what legitimate
net zero pledges and plans look like and
that could be a soft mechanism that
really would have a bit of teeth to it
in terms of all these companies using
the un as a platform to make these kinds
of announcements
judy finally do you have some optimism
that companies are moving in the right
direction
we are seeing a move in the right
direction but there are exceptions and
as jan very rightly pointed out shell
for example um where were focused on an
op-ed in the guardian just 48 48 hours
ago where they said the operational
plans outlook budget and pricing
assumptions
that they had given the public did
not reflect their net zero plans so
we're in a world where corporations are
stating one thing and doing something
completely different and that's not
right what we need is an alignment
between the state of goals of these
corporations and their actual
operational actions
right chitty od obahara thank you for
for persevering even though your line
was a little bit dodgy but we got the
gist of all you were saying and jen
allen thanks both very much indeed